good evening to you
evening first of all thank you for being
the first cabinet minister to grace
morgan uncensored with your presence
it's appreciated secondly i would
imagine you must be a bit exhausted
aren't you
it's a bit it's a busy time uh and you
know as commuters try to get themselves
into work um
the world has changed of course which
the unions don't seem to have realized
and many people uh simply working from
home where they can those who aren't are
the people that the unions claim they
want to represent but it's people who
need to get to work because their jobs
require them to be physically there
maybe hospital cleaners for example who
the rmt says they want to help they're
actually harming those people the most
and that's the great pity of what's
going on this week well i was actually
not referring to the strikes which i'm
about to come to i was afraid of the
fact that you get wheeled out to defend
the indefensible on behalf of your boss
boris johnson more than any other
cabinet minister it's a job that you do
with great
i don't know enthusiasm to write a word
but you certainly seem to embrace the
job the role of defending the
indefensible that's why i thought you
may look a bit exhausted oh i see well
look when it comes to the big subject of
today your introduction on the on the
strikes uh what i'm about to say is you
know very defensible what is
indefensible in itself is carrying out a
strike under a false pretence that there
won't be a pay rise when there was
always going to be one and sticking to
1950s rules which prevent our railways
from operating properly on behalf of
passengers so as that happens at least
for today i'm very very pleased to be uh
on your show and being able to put
across this point of view okay we'll
come back to boris johnson a bit later
let me just cut to the quick about
what's going on here a lot of people
feel that notwithstanding the fact that
technically you're correct network rail
is their job they're the employer they
should be negotiating with the unions
the country is in total chaos there's no
sign of this ending and when it comes to
direct government intervention in our
rail system i mean you couldn't have
done more than you've done in the last
two three years you missed pandemic by
piling 16 billion pounds worth of
investment of our money into propping it
up and saving jobs and so on which is to
your credit but that shows you are
prepared to directly intervene in
keeping our trains running during a
pandemic which prompts the question well
why aren't you getting involved now it
doesn't seem to me to be credible to
have done all this
for so long and now to say actually not
my job gov
yeah look i mean this is a negotiation
over
terms and conditions and pay
which is between the union and the
employer it is the only place that that
discussion can take place and uh it's a
stunt that the rmt mitt lynch are now
saying oh no
what we need are ministers in the room
that's a stunt because actually only
last month
mick lynch was saying we would never
negotiate with the government actually
he said we'd never go negotiate with the
tory government which might uh give
something about his frame of mind about
all this there isn't actually anything
helpful that i could do by being in the
room in fact it would undermine those
negotiations because they're not just
about pay they're about a whole host of
other things what the unions need to do
is get back in the room stop flouncing
out and get on with the talks you
clearly believe as a government that you
cannot give
the uh union that is currently running
this strike what they want for their
members they're demanding up to 11 pay
rises for their members you don't think
that you can do that why
yeah i mean as you say we were
incredibly i think everyone would say
generous with the railways with the
workers you mentioned that 16 billion
pounds that we paid during coronavirus
to keep them going and to make sure that
every single one of those railway
workers kept their job every single one
that's 600 pounds per household in this
country um so no one i think in terms of
motivations no one wants the railway to
succeed more than we do i love the
railways i want them to be per you know
really good for the 21st century for the
passenger in the 21st century but
reality are our realities we cannot just
keep pumping in hundreds of you know uh
hundreds of pounds per household in this
country uh to keep the railway afloat
when the passengers haven't come back
and the great pity about strikes is that
for every week of strikes as we've seen
this week what happens is it cost 150
million pounds to the railways that's
money that could be going to pay more
salaries which is instead going uh and
going to waste on these strikes so
actually making the position worse not
better uh through these strikes how do
you square though this kind of new
parsimonious view
of
capping effectively what you can pay
people in the public sector with this
revelation today that the government is
looking to scrap the cap on banker
bonuses
and that's not being denied by the prime
minister today at pmq so is that true
have you told businesses that they
because we're now not in the european
union they no longer have to abide by
that rule that they couldn't have more
than 100 percent bonus well the start
the government looks after the areas of
of uh the public sector which are under
its overall control you know teachers
nurses doctors
railways those are the things that we
can directly affect what the private
sector pays under different
circumstances is their business i hope
you'll forgive me i'm not an expert on
on city
rules but my understanding is that there
are always uh discussions and
considerations about particularly now
we're outside of the eu
where caps uh lie in all of this but i
will have to leave it to the treasury
and others who will be better informed
but clearly if the uk government is
telling people
in the banking world you can remove the
cap on your bonuses we're not in the
european union anymore haven't got to
abide by these caps off you go lads fill
your boots that does jar
very heavily with people right now who
are struggling to feed their kids or
queueing in food banks or indeed you
know people like mick lynch and half of
his members would say well this is
completely outrageous so i think it's a
perfectly valid question to ask any
member of the cabinet frankly
this is true have you guys given the nod
to the banking world you can give
yourself what you like as bonuses no i
know and then and this is the thing you
know what you get is a is a letter uh
which um which which i think may have
been leaked or something which is
actually a discussion i imagine within
government as i'm not involved in in
this particular area of policy
and so i wouldn't want to jump to any
conclusions on that at all presumably
those in the treasury are considering
how to make sure um that the city of
london which is uh one of the most
successful financial uh sectors in the
world which pays billions and billions
of pounds in tax which helps us to get
all of these public services uh remains
internationally competitive but as i say
that's a private sector activity uh what
i'm dealing with here with the with the
rail situation uh is the public sector i
do just want
because it is relevant um
don't run away with the idea that our
railway workers 100 000 of them are
poorly paid the medium salary the
average salary is 44 000 rail uh drivers
these are not the drivers on strikers
should point out but rail drivers median
average salary 59 000 a fifth of the mo
earn over 70 000 they're railway drivers
on over 100 000 pounds this is not a
badly paid sector nurses for example
would earn perhaps thirty one thousand
care workers i don't i don't i don't the
government has to i'm not unsympathetic
listen
i had a big i had a big set too with
mick lynch last week i'm not i'm not in
total disagreement with what you're
saying i think if you're going to start
shelling out big pay rises nursing staff
should be top of the list it would be my
view but i do think that this this issue
of the private sector and a word from
the government that you can all fill
your boots with bonuses it could not be
worse timed for you when you're trying
to have a position as a government that
there's not enough money in the pot for
the public sector if the same government
is going around removing any caps so the
people in the banking community can
enrich themselves yeah i think that's a
very unfortunate juxtaposition and i
would simply ask you you clearly your
position seems to be you don't know the
truth about this but if you if that was
the case
would you share my view that it would be
outrageous well well actually i was
going to say there's a fairly
straightforward principle the government
deals with the money that it taxes and
raises and then spends on things like
salaries the government doesn't
generally get involved in legislation
about what for example a tv presenter
could earn or could earn as a bonus
that's that's unusual now after the
financial crash uh governments around
the world have been more involved uh in
uh in in setting these private sector or
limits on private sector bonuses for
example it's not generally where what
governments get involved with as i say
you're slightly asking me outside of my
area of speciality i do know that the
city of london is responsible for paying
for
the taxes that allow us to have a lot of
our public services and i imagine that
the relevant ministers will be
interested in getting that balance right
to make sure we have a competitive city
of london uh which is able to compete
globally and bring in more taxes to pay
for all the public services that we want
in this country okay let me just finally
on these strikes mick lynch says he's
met every transport minister tory
transport minister in the last year that
presumably includes you
well he usually works with the railway
uh minister so they're a real me have
you meant it
no i don't i haven't met with him no
you've never met mate lynch uh not
knowingly no
not knowing me we think he's trapped
around your house when you're not
looking as far as i'm aware i didn't
want to mislead you that he was at an
event i was at once or something like
that but but no usually in england
you know i understand all your reasons
and rationale for not getting involved
as you say in negotiation but given what
is going on in the country it's the very
last thing anybody in this country needs
or wants right now surely there's going
to be a moment but it just makes sense
for you to pick the phone up to make
lynch and just have a conversation with
you so i mean ultimately you are the
transport secretary that is right but
there is a rail minister whose job it is
specifically yeah but you're his boss
right with with rail
you're his boss so how far do you take
this if there was a box
let me ask the question if there's a
paid dispute on your tv channel uh which
i believe is ultimately owned by rupert
murdoch would you expect rupert murdoch
to walk in and resolve that dispute i'm
sure he doesn't really
put it this way if the entire country
had been brought to its knees by
whatever was going on absolutely but the
point about this is you've got to have
the right people in the room to settle
these things i can't settle this dispute
it is a stunt asking for ministers to
walk into the room and here's why
if you listen to mick lynch you thought
this was about a single figure the
single digit what percentage pay rise
there should be it's not there are
another at least 20 areas of reform 20
areas where for example
at the moment there are jobs that
network rail have to send out to fix and
maintain the track where they have to
send two vans even when one van will do
where they have to roster people so that
an entire group goes out to do a job
that a single person or two people could
do for no good reason where we can't run
railways at the weekends on sundays in
particular because back in 1919 a sunday
wasn't a working day those are the
details of the negotiations that are
going on and the idea that a minister
walking into the room and somehow being
there would alter those negotiations
it's completely wrong in fact what it
would do is undermine the negotiations
and i hear mick lynch saying this as a
stunt to divert attention from the fact
he keeps walking out as he's done again
today of these discussions and by the
way i hear the labour party saying the
same thing which is interesting so i had
a look at the track record back in the
uh the blair days there was a very big
fire fighter strike
and the union said the ministers should
get round the table blair said no in the
brown days there was a post uh office
workers strike and the union said the
same thing and the bl and the brown
government said no ministers don't get
round the table because when he did back
in you know either 70s with harold
wilson beer and sandwiches at downing
street or beer and curry as i'm sure uh
uh sakir would prefer well you know what
happened was uh it was a disaster our
industrial relations were a disaster and
the country was disaster that is not the
way forward the way forward is for the r
t to get back in the room and sort this
out throughout the whole arena of the
different issues that need resolving
many of which are to do with the
modernization of the railway so it's fit
okay so mick lynch has a facebook
profile picture of himself as the hood
the evil criminal mastermind from
thunderbirds and i did suggest to him
when we discussed this in a rather
animated way on this show last week that
you were the kind of virgil character
from the thunderbirds we actually look a
bit like virgil and i pointed out that
in the end virgil does emerge triumphant
well i mean i i think we can take these
comparisons too far but
i i simply think you can't hold the
world back
against things which have fundamentally
changed for example uh it used to be the
case if you weren't wanted to go on the
train you'd have to go to a ticket
office and pick up your ticket now only
one in eight tickets are bought in that
way and yet we have exactly the same
number of ticket offices uh almost
exactly the same as we had in the 90s
before the internet got going
you had a situation where the only way
to check a track to maintain it properly
was to send people out and have them
walk along the track it's dangerous i
read accident reports often frequently
from people who've died because they've
been hit by trains as they try and
maintain the track and nowadays a train
can be fitted with sensors and cameras
and take 70 000 pictures per minute to
check that track much more safely and
more accurately than the human eye but
because the unions refuse to reform
themselves we end up with a railway
stuck in the 1950s and 60s that has to
change and he won't be able to hold out
against change because uh because he
just insists on calling his union
members out on strike and we the country
can't live with that let me let me ask
you about uh air travel because that
also comes under your remit it's
obviously been a busy time for you
what kind of grade would you give
yourself the way you've handled aviation
for this country since the pandemic
began well look i think aviation has had
a very tough time quite clearly um just
to put this into context
the government has provided eight
billion pounds and when i say the
government i mean
you the taxpayer whoever's watching this
has paid eight billion pounds to the
aviation companies independent companies
to keep them
afloat so i think we've done our part
would be my what i'd say i'd also
acknowledge that due to the stop-start
nature of the pandemic of the
restrictions it wasn't easy for them in
the end unfortunately
i think that they lost too many people
they're scrambling to employ them back
we're trying to do whatever we can to
help including changes of the law in
fact of today uh just made a second
change to the law to do something to do
with airport slots uh that the airlines
use uh to make it easier for them to
hand those back in to have a more
organized approach to uh their
you know what is a global problem
because if you go right but when you
still
it is it is a global problem when you
say you've done okay the iata who
represent 300 airlines including british
airways have concluded the uk
government's handling of the aviation
sector in the pandemic was their quotes
the poster child of what not to do
and the uk aviation sector ended up
suffering the worst of all of europe
during the pandemic that's not okay is
it that's a shame
i fundamentally disagree um first of all
other countries have got different
models which included putting a lot more
taxpayers money uh into uh these private
companies i think there's a balance
people don't want their taxes to
endlessly uh go up we did what we needed
eight billion pounds to help them
survive
uh but we didn't follow the model of
some uh governments which was to take
over effectively their their airlines
that is that is true but here's what we
did do we got out of the pandemic first
because we jabbed people first and that
was because of some phenomenal
leadership in this country that led to
margaret keenan receiving the first ever
uh jab that means we were released from
the lockdown we were released from all
the testing we're ahead of other
countries that probably gave our
aviation sector the additional issue of
having to try and recover faster i mean
i'm just going to say this let's not
present it as a british problem because
actually if you go to scribble or if you
go to the united states and go to dublin
everybody is experiencing the same
problem so let's not pretend it's some
sort of british problem no i mean and
also i do hear a lot of ministers
talking up how brilliantly we handle the
pandemic but of course we do have i
think still the highest death toll in
terms of people who died
no that's not no that's not true no not
right not death rate okay death toll
that's the physical number of people who
died well i don't i think the idea
the idea that the first phase of this
pandemic was was anything but a disaster
i think is for the birds but i want to
move on quickly to
we argued about that many times at the
time i i know and all i'd say is i think
in retrospect um there have now been uh
much more comprehensive and detailed
surveys uh published which take the the
global and european comparisons and
actually we did pretty well overall but
let's
give i give i give the government credit
for the vaccine program i give it credit
for reopening the country uh at the
start of this year i think those are
both good decisions which have been
completely vindicated and as you say you
look at it in totality but i think the
first phase of all this it was pretty
disastrous let me ask you quickly about
romania you've got prince charles you've
got boris johnson going out there um
prince charles you know it was briefed
and not been denied believes that the
government's rwanda policy of sending
people who try and come in illegally to
this country to rwanda is appalling what
is your response to that
well i'd never um comment on sort of um
royal uh
you know uh uh you know we haven't had
this confirmed or denied i never comment
on that anyway but i will comment on the
policy itself and that's simply to say
that i think what is incredibly inhumane
is standing by and watching people
drowning in our channel uh watching
people pay people smugglers and
criminals criminal gangs to bring them
to this country and other than ringing
our hands and saying this is terrible uh
simply not having a plan to deal with it
and that is essentially as far as i can
tell the position of everyone else every
other party every political party in
this country apart from the
conservatives party you may not agree
with the plan but we have a plan and
that is to ensure that people are put
off that we stop the uh the trade the
illegal trafficking people uh at it let
me ask you let me ask you
let me ask you do you really believe in
this because
how does this fly with the fact that you
personally have taken in a ukraine
family you've taken in a mother a young
child i think that the grandmother as
well and the dog
you've done this now for several months
with your family already a big family
you've done this selfless act of
humanity for people fleeing war-torn
ukraine
do you really feel comfortable having
done that it's incredibly laudable by
the way you're one of the very few
ministers that's done this
it's very laudable but at the same time
how does that sit with genuinely wanting
people to think you are happy
with people coming from war-torn
countries literally in some cases
washing up on our shore and the first
response in this country is to send them
off to rwanda in a plane well i'd say
two things um first of all
uh the family have come to stay with me
were fleeing from uh ukraine uh which is
a country uh at war with literally uh
missiles landing
by their house um they've come from a a
war zone to the united uh kingdom and
i'm you know i'm pleased that we've been
able to um
give them i call them evacuees rather
than refugees but i you know um you know
a safe place to to live but the people
in france are in france right they're in
a free country in a free european
country where they are absolutely
legally entitled to claim asylum so
they're not coming out so then they've
already come out of they're not in a war
zone in in france the second thing i'd
say is i've been to rwanda i don't know
how many people will have um done uh and
i know it is a uh particularly well
administered in terms of uh the
government in terms of the lack of
corruption in terms of its public
services uh country and i think
sometimes people hear
africa and they hear rwanda
and i'm not sure there's not a sort of
tinge to the way that some people
think about um this policy uh and
somehow think less of it because of the
location um what i know for sure
let me ask you are all the ukrainian
refugees are they all coming straight
from ukraine are they coming
no they're not necessarily they're sorry
i'm sorry but mister but by your
argument
the argument about using well look the
others are turning up at france and they
should be able to stay there what about
people who leave ukraine and go to
poland and then come to the uk i mean
it's the same argument some of these
people in france have come from yemen
they've come from syria where they're
both active wars others have come from
wars where we've been directly
responsible for the mayhem iraq
afghanistan so to me the moral argument
is the same and i simply ask you as
somebody who's had the
the goodness of his heart as a family
to take in this ukrainian family which i
think is an incredible thing to do i
just find it hard to believe that you're
that comfortable yeah i may have come
from similar places
fleeing oppression and war that you're
that comfortable with literally saying
no you're not coming in you're going to
africa so so let me let me explain why i
am um for a start with some of those
other locations that you mentioned syria
for example afghanistan we have had
programs from syria for example to take
in uh thousands of uh refugees and we
actually do it often from the displaced
camps so we we actually work with the un
and we bring people across we have to
recognize as a country that actually a
lot of time uh what happens is people
will move around the world for perfectly
good reasons for economic uh reasons and
that's you know a choice people will
make where people want to claim asylum
uh they're able to do so legally
it is irresponsible of any government to
allow a route and and i ask you what is
the other option to allow a route to
open up where criminals
criminal gangs and people traffickers
are allowed to be a legitimate route
into this country no no no i think i i
completely agree that's unacceptable but
it isn't seem to have managed to nothing
else has worked right we've taken what
70 000 ukrainian refugees in a matter of
weeks through safe routes yeah so my
response would be why are we not trying
to get similar safe routes for people
coming from other war zones yeah well so
so i will say people are able to come
here and climb and claim um asylum from
all around the world and that does
happen when they come here through a
legal route they maintain that legal
ability to do so uh what we have to do
is stop people from dying in the channel
and so far i've not heard anybody who
says well you know it's it's wrong that
people uh go to uh rwanda i've not heard
them come up with another solution
because there isn't anything against
rwanda but i've got a big problem with
the taxpayer shelling out 500 000 pounds
of pop for empty planes on time
well in which case let's in which case
let's tackle the law uh which uh sorry
not the law the the legal establishment
which will fight this endlessly and by
the way to put that into comparison we
spend a billion pounds a year on dealing
with the upshot of uh this uh uh
uh asylum uh system not working so uh
yeah i understand that it will cost
money to establish a new route but what
about all the money it costs to maintain
a system which is fundamentally
brilliant
people are dying not understand the
channel
you must do something about that i agree
if you keep being blocked though by the
law and the law is what it is it's a law
so they're they're currently that's i
mean you know the job i do in this place
behind me here is is is is changed the
law right the law isn't working i
understand but my point is to change it
my point is if you literally can't get
this plan to work at what point do you
abandon it and stop wasting taxpayer
money oh look i think we're only at the
beginning we're going to make the plan
uh work i mean we are a determined
government who do a lot of difficult
things whether it's you know long-term
social care that no government tackles
for a a long long time or a whole
leveling up agenda which is a for
another day possibly we do the difficult
things in this country we build the
infrastructure
the integrated rail plan 96 billion
pounds in the north and the midlands of
new railways
we are prepared to take those decisions
how would you feel how did you feel
though how would you feel if i said to
you
all right mr shatson sorry we're going
to take your ukrainian family and we're
going to put them on a plane to rwanda
tomorrow so my
the ukrainian family ukrainian family
that you're currently hosting yeah the
ukrainian family came that lives me
could you have that conversation
was gonna say they came here through a
legal understanding
i'm talking about this i'm talking about
the moral the morality of it really is
it could you imagine having that
conversation with them and saying
actually you're actually you're not
going to stay in safe
britain you you're going to go to rwanda
which has a pretty poor record
that's no more relevant than saying can
i imagine my family being asked to go to
randa i mean this is we're talking about
here people who've been trafficked by
criminal gangs
across the channel
illegally
knowing that what they're doing uh will
it is illegal and knowing that when they
get here in the future
there's a good chance that you will end
up being in rwanda and what will happen
in the end of course once that policy is
up and running is that it will close
down the criminal gangs and that will
save a lot of lives and we can
concentrate there's a lot of illegal i
think there's a lot of big if some
migration look there's a lot of big ifs
you know and again i ask you know to
people who who who object and and i say
sometimes they're saying it's on moral
grounds i slightly worry
that it's their reaction to the fact
this happens to be an african country
i've been an african minister so i know
africa
very well and i know that country uh
reasonably well it's well run it's well
administrated it has very low levels of
corruption by global uh corruption in
india it has a poor record on human
rights
when it when it comes to uh migration it
also has a very um good records as well
and i do worry that people talking about
this say it sometimes without really
appreciating or suggesting an
alternative to people dying in the
channel well i can agree with you that i
i agree with you what the other option
is well i agree with the characters
shut off i agree the current situation
can't go on but we did we did with the
ukraine emergency suddenly find
ourselves capable of taking in seventy
thousand and this country has been very
generous not just in ukraine
but in syria
in afghanistan in hong kong and many
other places we're in a very discussed
country let me ask you about what it's
been like to have ukraine family living
in your house
we have two cats and they they've moved
out the house largely to uh live in the
front garden they're not keen on the uh
ukrainian dog max who seems to scare the
living daylights out of our cats
there's been that there's been a few uh
adjustments um uh to make we're a room
short and so uh one of our uh one of our
kids is at uh as a university so we've
been using his room when he comes home
there's a sofa bed we pull out and what
have you so a few adjustments to make
but you know generally speaking um we're
we're you know delighted to have them uh
with us the
the the lovely people the country is
under attack and the way i feel about
what's going on in ukraine is it's not
just um putin attacking some country you
know across across uh in eastern europe
he's attacking all of our freedoms and
all of our rights and if we don't stop
him there he'll carry on west we've seen
this sort of thing in the world before
so i think it's a small price to pay to
have a family live with us
in return for you know trying to to help
with that situation well it's a great
thing that you do uh for that family and
i'm sure it's hugely appreciated by them
and by ukraine uh thank you very much mr
schatz to be my first cabinet minister
it's a pleasure
we went along with it because i wasn't
quite sure if we'll ever get another one
so thank you very much you're welcome
thanks
you